but don't quote shakespeare if you want
to wow
nbc's hoity-toity andrea mitchell did he
catch ted cruz yesterday
with bill and dana
well i think we'll see that the trial
continue for the rest of the week
um it it is reminiscent of shakespeare
that it is full of sound and fury
and yet signifying nothing
well nbc's andrea mitchell the queen of
condescension
wasn't going to let some cornpone
hicksville knuckle dragging no nothing
like ted cruz
get away with cod swallow like that so
she let him have it on twitter
senator ted cruz says impeachment trial
is like shakespeare
full of sound and fury signifying
nothing
no that's faulkner
as in william faulkner's 1929
southern gothic novel the sound and the
fury and unlike tweets about climate
change or dead people voting in michigan
that weird beard fact check jack didn't
put a public health warning on miss
mitchell's tweet directing you to more
reliable sources so the great herd of
stampeding morons
that is twitter began to pile on clary
ellis
he's canadian what does he know about
southern literature always the canadian
card the canucka phobia
papa michie obviously cruz only read the
cliff notes versions
of shakespeare tyler king ted cruz is a
person that thinks he is a rapier wit
and is actually a doorknob doorknob
ted cruz what a maroon he's like a cliff
notes version of a doorknob
and then someone pointed out what would
once have been obvious to anyone of
andrea mitchell's generation and in
andrea mitchell's position shakespeare
said it over three centuries before
faulkner
in macbeth which is a play about some
scottish bloke but let's not get hung up
on details so faulkner
was doing what ted cruz was doing and
quoting shakespeare in his book title
the left condescends to the right
unrelentingly
because that's one of the pleasures of
being part of an elite you get to
condescend
but we are ruled by perhaps the most
stupid elite in history an elite whose
ignorance is invincible
and impregnable why they presume to be
able to change the very heavens
through the paris climate accord so why
would they not also know better than you
about the obvious benefits of
outsourcing every worthwhile job to
china
while your daughter makes do with the
night shift at the quickie crap
and your son's face down in the meth lab
it takes a special kind of insulated
ignorance
i don't want to dance an entire
geopolitical thesis
on andrea mitchell's tweet she made like
yosemite sam
and shoved the dynamite down her own
pants it's not a big deal
except that the need to sneer is
revealing
as is the inability to sneer competently
it's no disgrace not to recognize even a
familiar line of shakespeare
but it is weird for someone who's been
on nbc for half a century not to be
prudent enough
to be aware that a big bunch of famous
book titles are
shakespeare quotes not just faulkner but
brave new world
that's from the tempest and band of
brothers that's henry v
and golly that's super cool tv hit
the dark tower that's king lear via
robert browning
there's an ancient joke about a first
time theater girl who went to a
production of hamlet
and complained that it was nothing but a
bunch of old quotations strung together
you don't need to have seen julius
caesar to appreciate the various songs
called the evil that men
do whether by iron maiden or queen
latifah
but you ought to have a vague sense that
it's the past that gives richness
and texture to the present they're the
mystic chords of memory
that stretch down the centuries from
some bloke wandering about
stratford-on-avon in dublin hose to a
pretentious lyricist in a heavy metal
band any functioning society
is like an iceberg 7 8 is below the
surface
and if you get rid of that what's left
just bobs around like flotsam and jetsam
until it melts into nothing as tucker
and i and others
talk about here almost every night right
now the wokarati are doing a grand job
at vaporizing
our entire past our shared inheritance
whether you're black white
gay straight trans or drearily binary
you're the beneficiary of this
inheritance whether you know it or not
and this public snare by one of the most
eminent members of our know nothing
elite is what will look like when the
job's complete
a profoundly ugly shallow and stupid
society
full of sound and fury oh hang on ted
cruz has already used that one
that's really my main objection to ted's
barge stick
the lines are wee bit over deployed and
almost too applicable
i mean that twitter spat was nothing but
sound and fury like almost all twitter
spats are
but it does signify something and
nothing good
about where where headed
here now is fox news contributor
joe concha joe do you want to add to the
pylon on
poor ole miss mitchell
follow mark uh yeah look here you have
andrea mitchell who's supposed to be
a serious journalist and a sober anchor
impartial in pursuit of facts
and here she is playing on the twitter
trolling senators to try to get some
cheap likes
on twitter and boy a lot of likes 10 000
likes on this tweet
so apparently the scary part about this
is 10 000 other people
at least did not know that that was
macbeth and by the way uh
inside sources tell me that andrea
mitchell actually meant harris faulkner
and not bill faulkner as far as
who she thought i mean i'm in favor of
quoting harris forknight again i'd have
gone with that
hey joe i gotta i gotta ask you uh about
this is bruce springsteen's ad
the fastest self-detonating super bowl
ad
in the history of the planet fact check
100
true and and look who were the ad
wizards that came up with this one mark
right
they're saying okay let's take this 71
year old guy who was relevant maybe 25
years ago
from the jersey shore we're going to
stick him in kansas
on a jeep make him look like a 21st
century
john wayne and then one of the most
partisan entertainers we know of out
there
who endorsed kerry and obama and hillary
and biden we're going to have him talk
to the nation
about unity so this is just amazing and
the fact that
here you have bruce springsteen worth 50
million dollars
right and there he is in sandy hook
jersey shore doing shots of tequila
you would think the guy might call an
uber and a ford festiva shows up or
better yet
you have a driver named chiefs that can
drive you anywhere you need to go
and you don't have to do this instead
it's like some sort of bad version of
porky's
except the main character is six years
above actual retirement age
it's just a sad thing and for jeep they
got to be shaking their heads like you
got to be kidding me any celebrity in
the
in the world we could have put on this
ad in front of 97 million people for the
super bowl and we picked springsteen who
never does ads
and now this is what happens the ad is
now done
again it's been taken off their youtube
channel yeah he does a less convincing
impression of a blue collar american
than an effect foreigner
like like me joe joe i got to ask you
this quickly
rachel dolezal the gal with the cravy
crazy hair
who uh wanted and purported to be
african-american uh her life's a
disaster
since she came out as caucasian
this is true and look before there was
cancelled culture you hear you had
rachel dolezal
cancel herself because she was being
somebody she was or in this case a color
that she wasn't but the reason why she
can't get a job at this point because
that's now the story that's out there
for
she's been looking for a job now for
years is the fact that i don't know how
this goes down in canada
but she's a felon she has committed
obviously welfare fraud uh obviously
records frauds as she's presented
herself
incorrectly in terms of getting public
assistance so
that's what happens your linkedin page
doesn't look all that good when a
you faked uh your your uh you know
nationality or in this case your color
and
and b obviously uh you've committed
several felonies it's going to be hard
to get hired at this point
it appears mark thank you for that joe